germany's players say spirits are high
ahead of their world cup warm-up clash
against cameroon
but they will have to cope without the
injured duo of team captain phillip
lahm and keeper manuel neuer plus a
skeptical mood amongst their own fans
i don't think we'll get that far this
year i've been optimistic before every
tournament over the last 12 years
but not this time
it'll take an emphatic win over cameroon
to lift german fans
the african team though have spent the
last year under countryman falca finka
think his life has been by no means easy
his players have fallen out with the
cameroon fa over world cup bonuses and
star striker samuel attor
is nursing an injured knee nonetheless
the players say they are raring to go
we're confident because we're one of
africa's best football nations
our goal is to play well and get past
the group stages
the goal for germany coach joachim lev
is more immediate
he must decide which three players to
leave out when he names his final world
cup squad on monday